il veut y sont membres de l'académie de
médecine bonsoir yves buisson merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
un confinement qui encore appelée à
durer
manifestation c'est une bonne chose pour
le médecin que vous êtes bien entendu ce
confinement doit durer tant qu'il sera
nécessaire
il est il est obligatoire pour l'instant
avec un objectif qui est de diminuer la
charge des hôpitaux notamment au niveau
des services de réanimation qui sont
submergés est temps que ces services de
réanimation seront en difficulté
le confinement devrait être maintenu et
ce qui est très inquiétant c'est de voir
effectivement le comportement d'une
faible d'une minorité de la population
mais qui est quand même suffisamment
importants pour maintenir la
transmission comportement irresponsable
de personnes qui ne respectent pas le
confinement
c'est la raison pour laquelle écision
2-2 le devrait être prise non pas
simplement les flots de ville qu'ils
font très bien comme comme sow mais à
l'échelon national
il faut savoir si on veut ans qu'on a
passé le cap des dix mille victimes
est-ce qu'on veut encore des mets mort
dans les semaines qui suivent
c'est un c'est vraiment une
responsabilité collective dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons et je pense qu'il
faut passer
malheureusement par des mesures assez
coercitives des mesures d'obligations
l'europe nous en sommes il mettant en
cause un petit peu perdu à un moment
donné pour un problème de réseau en tout
simplement j'imagine qu'en parlant de
saut vous faisiez allusion au port du
masque j'espère ne pas me tromper
puisqu'on a été effectivement coupé
pendant ce moment pour vous est ce qu'il
faut ou non le rendre obligatoire ce
vase sachant évidemment on n'oublie pas
franchement mais tout simplement on n'a
pas les moyens de le rendre obligatoire
en ce moment puisque tout simplement on
ne les a pas des masses mais selon vous
ce serait une bonne chose
de rendre obligatoire et on pouvait
cette politique pendant la coupure je
disais que l'initiative du maire de
sceaux est tout à fait louable mais elle
devrait être national pas limité auquel
des loups ile de france
ça doit être nationale parce que le
l'épidémie pour tout le pays même si
elle le couvre de façon inégale de façon
hétérogène il faut que tout le monde
soit conscient du fait que il est
potentiellement porteurs du virus qu'il
peut le transmettre aux personnes qui
l'entourent et donc le fait de porter un
masque dans les espaces publics va
arrêter du moins de deux ans grand en
partie les risques de transmission alors
le fait de dire oui mais des masques
nous ne rêvons pas ça n'est pas
recevable à l'heure actuelle on sait
très bien maintenant vous avez sur tous
les sites internet des conseils très
simple pour fabriquer avec selon qu'on
dispose chez soi avec du tissu avec du
coton avec eux matériel qu'on trouve
partout on peut confectionner un masque
qui aura tous une efficacité qui sera
même plus efficace qu'une la simple
écharpe miss devant son nez il faut
pouvoir couvrir son nez sa bouche
pendant plusieurs heures avec un un
tissu qui pourrait être réutilisables
lavables et c'est quand même des moyens
qui ne sont pas très compliqué avant on
puisse disposer de fourniture de masques
par le gouvernement si cela doit venir
un jour je voulais m'arrêter quelques
instants sur les chiffres qu'on appelle
c'est aujourd'hui la barre des 10000
morts dans notre pays
jérôme sa maman qui précise que le pic
n'est pas encore atteint alors que nous
sommes confinés depuis maintenant trois
semaines révolue est ce que le médecin
que vous et que vous êtes peut nous
apporter une explication
oui l'explication c'est que bon d'abord
il ya un retard entre la contamination
l'apparition des symptômes ont su que
c'est en moyenne cinq six jours 2
l'incubation donc lorsqu'on applique des
mesures il faut toujours observé un
certain retard pour observer leurs
effets mais quoi qu'il en soit façon
générale ce que nous avons observé au
cours du week-end dernier les sept jours
ci c'est que une partie de la population
ne respecte pas le confinement est ce
assez
on n'a pas d'autre moyen de lutter
contre cette épidémie
nous n'avons pas de traitement efficace
antiviral nous n'avons pas encore de
vaccin donc le seul moyen d'arrêter
cette épidémie c'est de stopper la
transmission pour stopper la
transmission ce sont les mesures
barrières et le port du masque peut se
rajouter peut augmenter l'efficacité des
mesures barrières comme la distanciation
sociale et le fait de se laver les mains
très régulièrement et c'est alors
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
évidemment test de traitement en cours
est ce qu'il y en a un qui apporte et
qui suscite peut-être plus d'espoir il
faut de tous les tests de tous les
traitements qui sont actuellement en
cours de l'évaluation
pour l'instant on ne peut pas dire grand
chose n'a pas de recul suffisant pour
dire tel test marc fait mieux que
d'autres
je pense que celui qui peut actuellement
donner le plus d'espoir c'est
probablement le l'immunothérapie passive
c'est-à-dire de l'utilisation de ces
roms de convalescents sous forme de
d'anticorps en qu'on va purifier on
appelle ça des immunoglobulines hyper
immune de province ont fait des poules
de plasma chaidron de pierre on mélange
le plasma de plusieurs personnes qui
sont convalescente de la maladie et on
va purifier leurs anticorps en injectant
ces anticorps aux personnes qui sont en
début de maladie
on peut les aider à se défendre contre
l'infection est éliminé le virus
ça c'est une bon c'est de ces demandes
bien entendu un certain délai de
préparation se demande des études plus
poussées mais ça a déjà montré son
efficacité et je pense que cette voie là
me semble actuellement plus sûr et plus
avancé que les molécules antivirales qui
sont en cours de test
on a compris
vous défendiez certainement logique le
confinement strict aujourd'hui le
premier ministre refuse à parler de
stratégies de déconfinement est-ce que
vous avez une une préférence un conseil
justement concernant sa stratégie on a
évoqué plusieurs choses de déconfinement
région par région par tranche d'âge
également quel est votre à nous alors
nous mon avis et c'est l'avis de mes
collègues aussi de l'académie de
médecine pour ce que nous travaillons en
gros peu nos étudiants nous prenons
beaucoup d'avis pour formuler une
recommandation
il nous semble que la meilleure
stratégie sera le moment venu de
procéder au dégoût déconfinement à
l'échelon régional
parce qu'elle est honoré de l'échelon
régional offre des possibilités de
décision et d'application des mesures
qui ont été prises meilleur et plus plus
réalisable que d'un autre et flon avec
la préfecture avec l' agence régionale
de santé
il est possible donc de d'encadrer les
mesures qui ont été décidées
l'autre stratégie qui est par tranche
d'âge alors intellectuellement ça peut
être intéressant on peut comprendre que
puisque les personnes âgées les
personnes à risque seraient donc
resterait en confinement alors que les
personnes qui sont moins à risque les
plus jeunes donc les enfants qui vont à
l'école les étudiants les filets tous
les actifs pourrait reprendre le travail
ces soldes c'est séduisant donc bien sûr
mais c'est impraticable parce que la
plupart de ces personnes vivent en
famille et on imagine que ce sera très
difficile de mettre ces mesures en
pratique à l'échelon des familles dans
sous le même toit vous avez des confiné
des non confiné qui vont vivre ensemble
comment faire comment éviter que la
transmission se fasse au niveau familial
on sait actuellement que c'est dans les
maisons dans les familles dans les
foyers que l'essentiel de la
transmission se fait et c'est parce que
c'est là que c'est le plus difficile à
éviter
aujourd'hui a aussi vu non la question
des tests quand on parle de
déconfinement cela vous paraît être une
des solutions pas miracle mais en tout
cas qui contribuera peut-être à
accélérer ce déconfinement ça peut aider
mes héros on met les tests on donne
beaucoup trop d'importance aux tests
alors que je suis microbiologiste que je
connais je crois beaucoup bien entendu à
l'apport du laboratoire mais les tests
il faut pas en attendre trop il faut pas
surtout en parler trop tôt parce que les
tests on ne les a pas encore les tests
qui sont actuellement sur le marché sont
en cours d'évaluation
la plupart ont été fabriqués en chine
certains tests ont été évalués se sont
révélés de mauvaise qualité donc ne
seront pas utilisées donc il faut
attendre encore un petit peu on va avoir
des tests mais vous savez c'est très
long de faire des tests c'est un virus
qu'on ne connaissait pas encore il ya
trois mois donc le temps d'identifier le
virus d'identifier les moyens donc les
reçoivent les le génome que ça a été
fait très rapidement pour le mettre en
pratique la paix sert pour détecter le
génome viral mais après détecter les
antigènes principaux qui vont servir à
faire les tests sérologiques se tient
rechercher des anticorps chez les
personnes ça c'est plus long c'est des
tests qui demande d'être longuement
choisi finalisé évalué avant de pouvoir
les utiliser et en tirer quelque chose
parce qu'on peut pas utiliser des tests
sans savoir ce qu'ils valent
les tests ont deux qualités c'est la
sensibilité et la spécificité et si on
ne connaît pas ses taux de sensibilité
de spécificités on ne sait pas très bien
quelle utilisation stratégique
on pourra en faire merci beaucoup yves à
800 membres de l'académie de médecine
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rtl
france merci m